so we're going to talk about annotation
tools in the edx platform and how they
break the unit directionality of online
content and you're going to see why
so why are annotations important
well maybe I'm speaking to the choir
here but really it's about breaking that
uni-directionality because when you
think about content online content it is
really a unidirectional flow of
information
annotations are really the new paradigm
of online learning even though you don't
really know it but it is it's what's
coming and there's a lot more coming
your way so what are the current issues
that we have with
online content
if we look at edx and these are real
examples you think about edx is a really
really monolithic environment and all
the information is flowing in One
Direction you have videos and you have
forums in these in these videos you have
information and in the discussion forums
which are completely disassociated from
the video you have information about the
video people are referencing the video
at timestamps if you look at some of the
some of the postings here you'll see for
example I'm sure this is answering I'm
curious if someone could enlighten me
where is this what's going on in the
video so
inside this video
this information is completely
dissociated we don't you don't you have
an information a reference from the
video to the video but that's in the
form the faculty is not going to come
into the to The Forum to find out what
what was going wrong with the video they
really it's so disassociated there's no
coming back to it
you need multiple forms of
contextualized Engagement so really what
annotations do is it contextualize the
information that you have at your hands
if you think of the courseware you have
tutorial discussions you have progress
discussions you have a general
discussions but all of these are
occurring separately right so we want a
way that we can aggregate all this
information
the multiple forms of engagements
basically when you talk about Blended
Blended content or personal learning
environments it's really about bringing
different resources into play and how
you put these all together and how you
evaluate these right
so if you think about the students or
Professor X currently is pulling
information from well maybe you know
your mooc and harvardx and other
Federated content maybe an extension
school maybe a faculty of Arts and
Sciences maybe content from Khan Academy
all this is
information that's that's not not
together not associated so if you think
of annotations they're really the glue
of that Blended learning it's really
what glues all this information together
if you can aggregate all these notes
together
when we're talking about multiple forms
of representation if you're familiar
with the udl University of design
learning principles
there's a lot of Learners that can they
can write very well but other Learners
really don't are not very articulate in
writing and maybe they express
themselves better via imagery or via
videos so being able to allow allow the
students to communicate via different
forms is really important and that's
what we're trying to do as well with the
annotations platform is is allow this
other other ways of Engagement with the
material
I'm going to go quickly about whether
The annotation tools that we've actually
created over the last year and how we've
used them in the courses in Pilot
courses so
we're using open source Technology based
on on on true and tried Technologies and
but we've extended these annotations so
we've we've used annotator as our
Baseline for creating the user interface
but we've also extended it to um
to to other features so you can add
plain html text you can assessment tools
you can have geolocation sharing groups
pre-populated tags and colored
highlights will show examples of those
in the courses and flagging annotations
of offense and offensive content for the
for the learners
one of the tools that that mostly that's
used uh quite a bit is the text
annotation tool and basically it's a
pretty straightforward annotation tool
where you have text you can highlight
and create your note and it's media Rich
note so you can add anything you want
text images video assessments anything
you want to add to those we've also used
uh we have a video annotation tool as
well it's based on the open video
annotation project that we launched
earlier on
this again uses open source technologies
that we're that we're leveraging to
build The annotation tool
and we then ported this video tool into
the edx platform so all coming from the
open source world the video annotation
tool is actually pretty interesting
because it we have some ways of
traversing annotations and browsing
through them and you can click and play
any one of these segments but you have
saw some basic analytics with it that'll
also show you where the where the
commentaries are happening inside the
video so difference from click stream
data where you're looking at where
people start in and end here you
actually see where people are actually
engaging directly with the content
we have deep Zoom image annotations so
high definition animation you can you
can look at art pieces in a very uh
high definition uh way and annotate in a
very detailed manner so there's just a
little screen grab of what The
annotation tool does how you can
actually go into details and whatever
you select and and annotate it'll record
that zoom level and you can come back to
it directly to that so whenever you
share one of these annotations you send
your link to somebody you can go back to
that exact point
all of these annotations so text image
and video annotations aggregate in one
page so students can go in and check all
their notes or instructors notes or
everybody's notes all aggregated in one
location
the notes themselves have the reference
to where they were annotated and so you
can click on that and it'll take you
directly back to that point so in one
point you have multiple ways of access
it's a it's a basic grid which displays
the commentaries and also replies from
the students if there were any
so how does this work is that basically
it's just it's it's tying in back in and
I'll show you an example here but like I
say like I mentioned before if in an
image annotation for example take that
fragment of that of that image that you
highlighted and you can click on that
and it'll take you directly to that
point in that image with zooming
directly into that level
how do we how do we work this is we have
a common uh annotation database which is
actually uh from a project from an open
source project that was uh started at
Harvard libraries
we take all this data aggregate it in a
common back end and then we normalize it
to open annotation data model which is
w3c group that is actually being created
now to standardize the annotations so
that we can have persistence over time
now I'm going to highlight
some examples of pilot courses that we
where we use annotation tools
one of the first courses that we piloted
was the heroes the ancient Greek hero we
did the first third-party tool in the
edx platform this was a a very
interesting Pilot Course but we didn't
really get much data out of it because
it was still isolated the information
was still isolated but we moved on to a
new Pilot Course which is poetry and I'm
going to invite Leah to talk about the
pedagogical setup and why annotations
were important in this course
um
for many courses on poetry that we're
running through harvardx that span the
entire chronology of American poetry
from Puritan poetry in early New England
to contemporary hip-hop so this was The
annotation tool is really the Capstone
of Engagement in this module
um because we wanted
to try to simulate a brick and mortar
kind of atmosphere as much as we could
and in a brick and mortar poetry class
we would expect everyone to
cover their book of poems in pen and
pencil markings but how to do this in an
online environment
so you know the first time you might
read a poem just without marking
anything and then you might read it
again marking times where you notice
interesting imagery or interesting
Rhythm or
meter syntax
and then you read it again and you mark
something else and this is the way that
you kind of come to understand what a
poet is doing what a poem is doing
so The annotation tool was really our
way to get at that in the online
environment and we had mixed results but
they were overall very very positive the
when I say mixed I mean that some
Learners were unwilling to learn a new
tool
for them being in the edx platform was
enough
but for people who did engage who
learned the tool they were extremely
enthusiastic Phil will go into some of
the data the numbers are pretty
staggering
um
they
the kinds of assignments we asked them
to do
um usually centered on a certain poetic
device
so we would say for example
this is what parallelism is find all the
instances of parallelism and then
comment on their effect in the poem or
something like that
uh we found that students were really
eager to complete the task
they didn't really
elaborate as much as we might have liked
them to and so that's one of our goals
for future iterations of use of The
annotation tool in the Poetry in America
modules we want to help students gain a
more complete understanding of why we
annotate and kind of Empower them to
annotate more fully instead of
simply
marking okay here are the tenances of
parallel instances of parallelism do I
get my certificate now
so Phil will go into some of the data so
I'll give you a little glimpse into the
data this is really preliminary data
that we're doing that we've done the
enrollment was about 13 000 students of
of which uh 386 uh got a certificate
that's about a 2.8 percent completion
rate but if we look at the detail of The
annotation data we had a thousand
students over a thousand students that
were engaged that created over 60 000
annotations that's 12 of the enrollment
so it's a higher percentage of the
people who finished completed their
their information so we have about 8.3
percent of students that were actually
engaged with the content so much higher
much higher than what the certificates
were
we in the course annotated about six uh
16 passages from 14 poems
um it was a pretty steady flow of
annotation data this is daily uh data so
you see up to 3 000 annotations in a day
I'm usually averaging about a thousand
annotations and about 90 individual
users daily and every
um every uh release date you could see
like a little Peak but this is not
really very interesting information
overall because it's a lot of quantity
but when you start to look at individual
data this is really really fascinating
when you think that some students
contribute up to 700 annotations some
very prolific students and it's not just
an edge case it's it's a steady normal
curve that drops down so we have people
that have been engaged you know 600
annotations 400 annotations and so and
so forth these are the top 500 users
that that we're looking at so we have
about a uh average per individual 150
and about maximum of 700 annotations
now if we look at the annotations of all
the poems so we can see numbers you know
on average about 3 000 annotations per
passage that's incredible amount of
information just on on the poems but if
we look at sort of the data over the
different parts when they were released
because some of the parts were from the
same poem so uh part one of them one
poem was released the first week another
part we released the second uh other
parts of that were released the other
and the other section and so and so
forth if we look at the aggregation of
this information
we look at for just one poem for example
song of myself over 22 000 annotation
it's really incredible the amount of of
data that's been contributed to just one
poem in one class over seven weeks is
outstanding
we did encounter some issues it was not
easy
students did have some problems with the
user experience we have a problem with
scale
it's how do you represent thousands of
annotations in a text how do you
highlight them it starts to be unlegible
that's really you know these are issues
that we are encountering we didn't know
what we're gonna we we predicted some of
these issues but but we realized that
there was a lot of problems there's also
engagement how do we stimulate the
community participation how do they find
discover there's a lot of work to be
done at the user experience level and
then Discovery how do we find meaningful
peer annotations how do people Traverse
these annotations so they can make some
replies and some meaningful
conversations or maybe if we have an up
voting mechanism we can upvote them or
downvote them right so
this is this is a a sort of a slide that
that Leah talked about but you know why
do we annotate and how to annotate those
are the pedagogical questions is is more
deeply do you want to talk a little bit
about that so Phil mentioned this this
question of how do we how do we allow
students to navigate each other's
annotations to make more conducive to
discussion
um that kind of brings us back to one of
those initial points that showed
um how the video and the discussion
right now in the edx platform are
disaggregated and that's something that
we would ultimately like to do is kind
of integrate The annotation tool and the
discussion forum in a normal brick and
mortar poetry class setting we would
probably
ask students to annotate a poem before
they came to class
so read the poem that annotated as
homework they would come to class the
teacher would you know give a brief
introduction lecture and then they would
break out into discussion groups
and we would never grade an annotation
in class or even really look at an
individual student's annotation but we
would expect that they would use that
annotation as the basis for their
contribution to the in-class discussion
and so ideally it would function in a
similar way in an online environment
that students would be able to really
use their annotations in this tool and
in their notes section as
a kind of jumping off point for a really
fruitful discussion
um and right now we haven't structured
in the platform so that they do The
annotation then they watch the video and
then they have a link to a certain
discussion thread where they can you
know pursue that Avenue of thought but
it would be great to really integrate
everything as I mentioned earlier
we took for granted in this pilot module
that students would know how we how
annotation works and they would have
some sense of why annotation is
important and what we found is that that
was largely not the case
so when we said annotate for parallelism
they would literally
Mark the instances of parallelism and
that's all they would do they didn't
have a sense that they could just read
and as something struck them they could
make a comment and engage with someone
else's comment and so that's one of our
main tasks for our next module which
launches next month is to give people a
more holistic sense of
why you annotate and to empower them to
come up with their own prompts in a lot
of cases
so this is crucial really what what is
the meaning of annotation and why is it
so important it's awful of course the
basis of a lot of research right in
engagement close analysis
Yes actually so I will some examples
from the China X will will reveal some
of those prompts um there's instructions
above every single annotation exercise
I'm going to talk a little bit about
China X I'm not going to give so much
data as I did for the poetry because
we're actually there's a paper being
written about that and there'll be more
information about it but China X was
also an incredible experiment because it
was huge the amount of information that
they that they unloaded to this to the
Learners so we had 30 texts from the
scholars and one large image was the
first release of a large 30-foot scroll
that students can actually have access
to and annotate
in this
um so one of the the interesting parts
of this is is to compare the two the
text to the scroll because the text was
actually a depiction
um from the literary that was not as
nice about the society then
um as the scroll because the scroll is
actually uh commissioned for the emperor
so it was a much more Rosy picture so it
was important for students to actually
read the text and see what was in the
text and how did it compare to actually
this Rosy picture in this scroll I'll
give you a few examples so we introduced
the the idea of concept tagging it's
kind of the incipient it's the beginning
of ontological tagging and I'll explain
that a little bit later but here's here
are some of the prompts that we had uh
for the instructions so these are all
built by some of our colleagues here and
we have some of our China X that we'll
be able to engage with during the
conversation later on but here you see
some of the prompts that were that were
issued here and we had guiding
contextual questions that and we had
some embedded surveys as well these were
because of the nature of The annotation
tool you can actually grab some qualtric
surveys and embed them in there
so if you look at some of the
instructions they were very specific
you know and and students had to
actually go through these instructions
and make sure they understood what was
at stake here
you can read through them I'm not going
to read through all this but it's just
an example of what we've done so here I
have a little screen grab of what the
scroll looks like if you take the if you
go to the China course and enroll for it
you could probably still see it but it's
a huge huge scroll with a lot of detail
a lot of scenery the the there's a lot
of a little bit of pixelation uh within
the image but you can see that you know
on the scroll itself on this on the
monitor it's actually much more detailed
and you can see sort of very you know
depictions of each one of the so there
it is it's kind of rendering that's
that's basically The annotation tool
that we use for this and it's also based
on open source technology and here just
an example of how Unity just click on
The annotation just it's the same
interface that you saw before that we
were using
all right that's an example of that I
won't go through another Dragon but you
can see how how long this scroll is
anyway we also carried on some a b
testing and we wanted to understand you
know does the active annotation image
impact students learning outcome in
China X and does the image annotation
impact students engagement with the
learning material this a b testing was
done through some little manipulation of
XML and the pages and we could present
some content to students and some other
con and some other content to the
students and we can talk about the
details with the China X folks a little
bit more about how that worked we're
still are analyzing this data we don't
you know there's probably some not very
conclusive data and I'll explain why as
well so Forum feedback those tools are
not perfect and it's a very difficult
technology to implement worldwide so we
had some people that are really mad
about these Technologies they didn't
want to deal with it they didn't want to
learn another technology they had 30
texts to read 30 texts to annotate plus
annotate a scroll
they said you know we're not here to be
learning new technologies they're not
perfect
but of course we have a whole
demographic that we're we're addressing
right so we've we're people who adopt
technology and people who don't really
like to adopt technology so we had all
kinds of feedback we tried to look at
all the feedback and try to to take that
back into into this iterative
development process that we have
so the preliminary results from China X
are also very interesting we've got 20
000 annotations over 9 000 tags a lot of
it was tagging right so a lot of
information uh gathered in tags
um there were about 800 individuals and
a span of five weeks again it's not as
much as the Poetry but but that's not
all they had to do in the China X
there's a lot more to do they were very
active creating over 2 000 annotations a
day during the first week and you know
as a module uh tapered the it was about
500 a day so we still have a lot of
information of Engagement it's
fascinating to see that
so what is next for harvardx well we're
not just going to stay there and stand
around and cross our fingers okay we
call it done what we're realizing is
that we need to improve them the user
experience absolutely so we're trying to
change the ways annotations are
displayed for example if you have a lot
more annotations on a text how you can
group them and see them in a site so
we're implementing a grouping function
it's actually being released this week
accessibility accessibility is a big
issue accessibility within the edx
platform is not is not fully functional
so we have issues with accessibility
with the platform itself but we also
have problems with accessibility with
the tools we're using third-party tools
that are open source tools so we need to
to go back and modify these and put them
back in the in the repository
fortunately we're actually working with
a community that's building these tools
and we're trying to steer that that ship
so we can make them more accessible
there's new releases that will be coming
through
new annotation dashboard you can't
really tell it because here it's it's a
little bit washed out but instead of
that you know know a grid where you have
information and dashboard with all the
annotations it's being able to display
them on the side show The annotation or
maybe in real time and maybe show a
little bit of Graphics of what's going
on so we can click on that graphic and
and and display all those annotations
that are based on some some information
that you want to see who are the biggest
uh contributors who are the people who
are actually talking or upvoted upvoted
annotations and those we're going to try
and work with different organizations
like hypothesis that it's gonna that
already has one of these side uh
dashboards we're also looking at
comparative analysis a lot of uh
research and and and and study in
pedagogy is is about comparing comparing
the two so if you could compare the
scroll to the to the other text and have
actually a way of connecting these two
annotations in a way that's meaningful
you can then show how how the the the
the information traverses between
different media types but then you know
when you think about annotations it's
students it's their student no they've
been taking notes throughout the course
what what happens with most of these
notes and other platforms they get stuck
so we want to be able to export this
information so students can carry their
their sort of portfolio for their course
this you know it's extremely valuable
because the notes have everything the
notes have a reference back to the to
the original document that they
annotated so they can click back and see
what they did they could take these
notes and copy them and make a paper if
they had if you know if we're taking the
smoke in a in a brick and mortar
classroom they could you know extend
extend these notes and use them for
their own assignments
where are we going also is LTI I don't
know if you're familiar with LTI but
it's the learning tool interoperability
so it's you can take a tool and plug it
into other Learning Management platforms
edx is a great platform we have a a
large population using the edx platform
but in a lot of the brick and mortar
classes we don't use edx and for for
Harvard and for other groups canvas is
actually one of the the big ones that
we're going to be using but there's also
desire to learn and all of them are
starting to adopt LTI so being able to
build a tool in LTI and then have it
portable into all the other learning
learning platforms will make it much
easier and much better to adopt for
other people and you just make one
investment and then it it Cascades down
to the other ones so we don't know who's
going to be implementing more LTI but we
know that edxes canvases and other uh
platforms ontology semantic tagging we
can talk more about this in the
discussion when we when we're talking
about a more precise tagging but this is
really important because a lot of the
ontologies are really in the sciences
and we would like to see more ontologies
for digital Humanities we're starting to
think about poetryontology Chinese
ontology and classic ontology that if we
get those modules in then we'll be able
to use them and I'll explain ontologies
a little bit more during the discussion
assessment rubrics imagine just in time
feedback you can put an assessment
rubric with an annotation So within a
fragment of video what did you learn
from this video answers right there you
don't have to go back to survey after
you've seen this video it's actually
contextualized to that fragment of that
video this is very very powerful
and then analysis and visualization
looking at a retroactive analysis
visualizing the data seeing what is
Salient what is what has been going on
what are the edge cases how are students
engaging with information so anything
from looking at uh specific pie charts
with you know proportions of data but
also looking at where is the annotations
happening in the world where is the
activity where are people really
engaging with the material is it
different from different locations uh as
you saw during the keynote presentation
today's is looking at the regional
perspective this is super important you
know how does it how does somebody from
uh America
interpret a text versus somebody from
Europe or versus somebody from Asia or
Africa very different uh sociological
backgrounds that that will give you a
very different interpretation of what's
what's being at stake so being able to
see those differences is is really also
fascinating
so we're working with multiple groups uh
different please different universities
uh we're collaborating we're
collaborating with with a lot of people
they're listed here and we're continuing
to to bring in more people there that
want to to help us out
and you know we talk about learning
tools for learning but think about
research right what are the research
potential for annotation tools if you
think about the crowdsourcing potential
and massive data if you put out an image
that has never been seen so there's
there's some some images from
manuscripts that have never been seen by
no one except for very few Scholars
right now you can have access to high
definition images students can start
looking if you look at some of the uh
some of the venetus A and B The homeric
Poetry that these manuscripts were just
released nobody had seen them before
they're released about you know three
four years ago now the public can see it
some of the some of the annotations the
actual annotations on the margins the
marginalia had never been seen never
been transcribed and never been
interpreted so now we have an ability to
look into that and and what it's being
done through crowdsourcing actually some
of the students just basic entry-level
students that are actually doing some
pretty high level research just by
looking at these
so it's really the model of research
drives teaching and teaching drives
research it's really about that it's
about bringing these research tools
because analytics close analysis uh
annotation tools are really about a lot
of the foundations of research
so we want to do future data analysis of
you know how do we how can we compare
student engagement do we do completion
rates how do completion rates compare to
annotation engagement are the more
engagements also want to complete the
course do the annotations exercise
increase the completion rates and
hypothesis and a b testing so a lot of
information we can still gather and
looking at retroactive data analysis
this is fascinating stuff that we can we
can start looking at is structural
topical modeling so words associated
with each topic do there is are the
commentaries we're really reflecting the
the themes that we are presenting in the
course or you know syntactic pattern
recognition the arrangements of words
and phrases are they using the right
words and phrases to express what
they're trying to explain
and then there's interviews with course
participants and instructors to find out
what what went well what didn't go well
and try to understand better what the
engagements is so if we look at
discovering annotations there's a lot of
um text analysis tools there but there's
some fascinating ones out there that
we're trying to bring in things like
this is textures it's really a Wordle on
steroids where you can actually see
connections between words within a text
it takes a text and parses it all out
and looking at Connected content so how
does this content connect to this other
content so how do you connect the this
part of this fragment of this text to
this to this specific point in this
image and what what is the comparison
there
you know it's not just all about click
stream data click stream data is
interesting but it doesn't give you the
full picture it just gives you what
people have been clicking and really
what annotations do is actually allow
you to look at at that detail so what is
the big picture and I'm wrapping up here
is
we want to think about a persistent
annotation meta layer and we have stage
stable digital repositories so we're
annotating content we're not any text
we're entertaining images and where are
these images deposited they have to have
permanent URL so we can refer to them
over time and really what we have is an
ephemeral content it's a learn all these
Learning Management Systems today it's
edx tomorrow it's yesterday was Moodle
to today's edx tomorrow is what canvas
design who knows what it's going to be
right but we need to make sure that this
doesn't matter but we keep these
repositories stable with stable URLs and
with the persistent annotation metal
layer so that the future students can
actually read what the annotations were
done by the other students in the future
in the past
so it's really about removing that and
keeping those two so we're looking at
persistent annotation repositories we're
building databases that are Federated
that can talk to each other that are
open so you can actually bring
information from external repositories
internal repositories and individual
repositories
theatric sanitation tools are right now
all the information about the edit
sanitation tools you can look at that
tiny URL if you want it's not going to
be permanently
hosted there but for now if you're
interested in looking at the tools and
how you install them on the edx platform
it's there there's a little caveat that
you need a back-end database the
information is also there but you'll
need to install it or we can provide
maybe some testing environments if you
want to look at them there's also more
information at the
annotations.harvard.edu sort of the
history a little bit of what we were
looking at and looking at all the media
types you're not just thinking about
text images or video but we're also
looking at 3D imagery
location-based annotations
audio annotations the whole gamut so
annotating databases annotating
repositories and things like that
that's all I have you can download the
slides at this tiny URL it's about a
seven megabyte
file and if you have any questions
we're opening it up
yes
see what is annotation means so this is
new to me so it's it's too hard it has
two purposes so student can either take
notes in an exact spot or they can be an
instructional tool to say tag these
things and then we'll see if you see
what you did
is that yes it's it's a very plastic
environment and it allows you to do
multiple modalities that you would like
to use so on one end at the individual
level I can go in and as a student take
notes across these texts or videos and
keep them right so these are my private
notes at the instructor at the
instructor level I could give guiding
questions as how you should annotate
this text and you know highlight the
areas that we talked about in the course
and annotate them but also I can
actually as an instructor create
annotations and type in some information
that illustrates how I should annotate
or how you should annotate or as an
instructor I can also introduce some
survey questions within The annotation
so multiple
yes
the video to get back to the spot since
it takes me
a great thing but I'm also wondering
really how that equates to engagement so
if I'm just sort of note-taking or you
ask me to do something I'm going to have
to do it to do the assignment but how do
these thousands and thousands I mean we
see that in the forums I'm not sure I
don't understand how that necessarily
relates to engagement let's talk more
about that okay so if you think about
the Forum The Forum people are
exchanging information right and they're
talking about let's say this video or
that material that that we had to read
but all that is in the forums
but as an instructor rarely the
instructors actually go through entire
forms and read and say oh this equates
to this video this part in the video I
should look and see why they're so
confused
so so annotations I like to pinpoint
that index or contextualize that
information if you think about how do
you measure engagement with videos on
online today with a student
so when you present a video how do you
how do you measure that engagement how
do you know if people have been going
through your video
it's basically click stream data right
it's looking at where did the students
start and stop and we're recording that
but you don't know when when somebody's
doing that on the back end is you're a
student you press the video you're
playing and you're in the kitchen
cooking up something and not really
looking at the video and it's still
playing well that's recorded that's data
that's being recorded a lot of people go
go through information like that or
they're they're playing the video and
they're actually reading Facebook or or
doing something else right that's
typical students these days with The
annotation you actually people have to
go in select actually type in put a
comment and say well this is where this
is happening now you have a
contextualized engagement it is actually
the student writing something about that
fragment so you actually they have to
have been looking at that video to
really make that also just to clarify
there are multiple different types of
annotation we're talking about so Phil
just now is talking about video
annotation which is where students are
annotating what they're watching for
poetry we just use text annotation China
with this role we are talking about the
video annotate image annotation
and sometimes we'll give them specific
prompts like Mark every time you see
imagery you know animal imagery or
something and sometimes we'll just say
you know
annotate the poem for you know
interesting moments that you notice I
mean in a more articulate way of course
but um then they kind of pray their
notes so sometimes and it's a it's an
assignment and sometimes it's just an
opportunity a tool for them to aggregate
their own thoughts
yes how do you handle the HTML safe in
the tech support changing underneath the
adaptations
a good point um so in general what
happens is that we are the The
annotation tools right now are are a
tool where you actually have to upload a
text or paste a text in it and the text
remains stable so the text is not
changing soon it's not a Wiki where
people are actually changing the text
access to
this too it has it is actually next
module more than x Block it's actually
part of the core these tools because
Xbox are not working yet fully so so
these tools are actually part of X
modules they're they're fully baked into
the into the core
yeah so yes just like any other tool
that you would be putting some content
onto the edx platform it's a tool where
you add you have to add the image you
have to add the video you have to have
the text that you're going to annotate
but there's certain certain uh there's
the technology is being worked on for
fuzzy mapping where you can actually
have an environment where the the text
changes and it still finds where The
annotation is that's that's being worked
on
to do is I'd like to have
when I talk street fighting math
students often would say Well I'm
a lecture week three and this point and
that point where the instructors that
lie didn't understand that and it takes
me forever to go back there I would have
liked them just in the reading to people
without having to upload anything to
anything else yeah so is that is that
what's been working on that you can do
that actually so you can you can
highlight and
tell you you know when we build it
originally you'd have to you'd have to
build it as annotatable text so instead
of just you know insert HTML component
we you would say you know insert
annotatable HTML component and so you
build it from the get-go and then that
makes everything annotatable yeah
go towards the back and then we'll try
to come to the front so I'm around
it got into trouble because it wasn't
his work and you know what it did and on
the other side I went to a talk today
she said well we all create together we
get more
because I don't know where it stands
because frankly as a student it's almost
in the process of annotating that
teaches me something rather than looking
at other people's annotations and so I'm
wondering where you want to how you
negotiate that balance between a process
of the process of learning through
annotation versus sharing everyone's
annotations because I don't know that
there's that many different things to
say about these thoughts how many things
are redundant and how many things are
you need to have that it's the process
of them being original to you not to be
shared with others and so it's a
beautiful it's a beautiful system and I
think it's very creative how are you
negotiating that balance between the two
sides so there's there's modalities that
we're that we're implementing in the edx
platform that allow you to actually
create instructors annotations but
nobody else can annotate so there's
there's everybody can annotate
instructors can annotate students cannot
annotate
I mean all these systems are being
developed but right now you can you can
do certain levels of of sharing what we
do for the Poetry course is we have when
a student logs in the default is they
see that blank just the poem text by
itself
and we ask that they annotated first and
then they can click a tab that says uh
public there's there's one that says
you can I'll just pull up one of those
images so it's that you know they just
have their personal annotations and then
they can see the public annotations that
shows everyone's and they can see the
instructor which is the instructor's
annotations but the default at least for
the Poetry course is always that they're
given the blank poem first
um and we actually always give them the
blank poem before they even watch the
lecture about the poem so they do have
that experience of the initial encounter
with Language by themselves you can't
really see it here because it's a little
bit washed out
but
um yeah it's it's washed up but it says
here it says my notes and here's my
notes and public notes and there's also
another one that's instructors so you
can actually click on it but by default
it'll just show you the your notes and
if it's a blank space
you talked about the Dilemma you were
facing between acting annotation and
what I would call Active impact so a
passive adaptation you need to give him
a question you didn't have a problem but
then they're going to go look for things
and then they just sort of rotally find
all these apples right and instead you
would like them to think and be active
about their annotation and that's
something I've done when I get a blank
page right but it strikes me that
there's a huge amount of latent
information when one does that even when
I annotate a text like my tech my poetry
book this paper and I highlight
something behind that it's just a
trigger for a lazy thought in my head I
don't actually necessarily put that in
margin it's appealed for my thinking it
is a way we can get to that late
configuration as well we do we you know
we consider an annotation it could be a
blank annotation but it's still an
annotation the fact that you're marking
that it is an annotation the fact that
you that you dog year a page that's an
annotation an active annotate you're
taking a note because you're you're
giving yourself a reminding sort of
marker but it is a note is it it is an
annotation it's a very broad definition
but it it it covers all the Spectrum
yeah and that's one of the reasons why
we gave these prompts right and some
sometimes the prompts that we give
we try to make them double layered so we
might say
find alliteration
and then comment on the effect the
alliteration has so we give them kind of
a two levels of questions not because we
necessarily only want them to focus on
alliteration in that poem but because
it's a way to get them started and then
hopefully it will kind of free them up
to be more creative but it's a good
question I mean if you have any thoughts
I'd be happy to hear
and yes it's really hard one thing
that's interesting is that we switch
from annotating as these are just my
notes to having a conversation with
other Medical in the class because that
people shouldn't become a little bit
more performative and clear and
articulate about the kinds of things
that they're thinking so but it's all
about how you prompt them and what what
you're encouraging people to do as
they're reading so the making it
socialization one way to make a little
bit is less more visible
yes so there's two two comments so one's
comment the other is a question
um so the common is that I think that
there are a couple of different kinds of
personal my name is educational audit uh
Microsoft research in India and we've
developed some tools for annotation and
video but it's for a different reason
which is basically
making share Improvement of the video so
you've got a lot of hours of video and
you're sort of You Know video is hard to
edit once it's set in place and so one
of the things we were really interested
in was are there ways in which you can
get the crowd to improve the video over
time and evolvement so we built a system
called bid Wiki you can go to
vidmickey.org and play with it it's
online it's available you can think with
it having to talk more about that but so
it's a different reason for using it I
think that there are sort of a palette
of things you can do with annotation for
different reasons that's the comment the
question is if you taught them awesome
yes it's Wiki then Wicklow video Wiki
within
v-i-d-w-i-k-i dot o-r-g
um the question is we've I've heard you
talk a lot about production
of annotations and you know they
generated all the different annotations
we've seen thousands of these things all
this kind of stuff what I didn't hear
you talk much about is analytics of
consumption
of annotations whether your own whether
they're others how are students sort of
using these as as pulling them in and
how do instructors or other people
understand what they're doing with them
so
um very good question the what we are
what we're trying to do is look at the
click stream data of how people are
browsing through the annotations
as I mentioned in in one of the slides
is one of the realizations is the the
scale Dimension the discoverability the
way we have our user interface is not
the most conducive to to discoverability
so that's a first barrier we need to to
overcome that barrier before we can
really get some some realistic
information
my hypothesis my thought is that there's
not much browsing of annotations
one is is the assignment is is really is
what the instructor is really giving as
an assignment is create your annotations
students if you think of the mindset
it's like I gotta get through this
exercise and I'm going to get a
certification I'll do what is required
but I'm not going to do any ancillator
work if you put ancillary material only
lifelong Learners will look at it but
not really engage with it right so I
think the the the discussion the
the settings has to be set the the
information has to be set from the
instructor's point of view is I want you
to engage with the students I want you
to find 10 annotations and and and
comment on them or find something that's
related to your topic but that to to
have that part of discoverability we
still need something that's more robust
as a user interface and what not robust
as in technological robustness but as in
interface robustness so yes absolutely
that is something that that we
definitely want to look we have the
click stream data from the from The
annotation data to any of the students
um so we we are so what we because of
the edex the the way edex is is set up
we have the information we have the
information for each one of the students
that's some of an outlet
um Emily talk a little bit more but
she's going to be doing some of the
interviews to students and instructors I
I'm sure
um
it's it's delicate
oh good that's worked out okay
um
and I've also been doing some work in
through user testing on prototypes of
things that are moving beyond this look
as we're bringing those together and so
on and there do we have like a fair
amount of like ideas and strategies and
then it's more of a development resource
constraint so yeah so ideally we can get
it thanks but yeah so it's really you
know cold calling some of the students
are like hi we've seen that you've been
engaging this course
we have to make sure that we're not
roughly any phase and we're not
crossing any berries that we shouldn't
be Crossing yes
um you had said that like two
percent-ish death certificates and eight
percent were engaged we were able to say
anything about the demographics or
intent like of those eight percent did
they already intend to be active in the
course or were you able to maybe like
you know move them over maybe more
accurate yeah no I you know honestly all
this has been happening so fast right so
on one side we're we're working on the
technology on the website we're trying
to establish the exercises and often
believe it or not because of the nature
of of how we where we are in this edx
world is that the development happens
and we finally are able to get them
ready for deployment almost
one or two days before the class starts
um so we haven't been able to plan all
the details but yes that is all
information that we would like to gather
I mean it's not I mean not only if you
want to
mention something about it I don't know
yeah that's it's a really good question
right right but we haven't done that we
haven't
we haven't
um done analyzed done that we haven't
done the calculations the the demo I
mean
we have all right now we're just
starting to analyze the data
we have some teams that are actually
starting to look at the details of the
data some of the data we need to clean
up some of the data some of the data
that comes from edx we need to match
that edx data to The annotation data is
in a different uh database and we need
to pair those up and see how they
compare so we have the the demographics
data from edx and now we have to pair
that up with the demographic with the
IDS that we get from the annotations and
that's a tedious process as you know and
trying to to correlate all that
information it's probably going to take
over the next few months but that's
something that the research team has
time to look at
trying to think of a way to link this to
research that's been done in Psychology
navigation that might give us some of
these issues so there's this sort of
Effect called self-explanation so if you
explain a concept with someone else plus
after someone is better than having
exhibition given to you I think in the
mirror at this point about
um when people make annotations should
you know should you just delete them or
should we give other students and
actually this might be a nice parallel
way we can ask that question in many
contexts it should be so give you an
annotation that fills in so many details
or should we prompt you to create one or
should we do both you know
so what we did was we had the image we
did our image and we just gave one
person layer of students just eventually
zoom in and out but they couldn't
annotate it or there were no different
transitions on it and then the second
group had justice of your annotations in
it um and they could really helps to
start the first one that they couldn't
get it to get and the third group had
the instructor annotations in it and
they could annotate it and so and then
we gave that we gave them the
assessments after that and then
everybody got the annotateable questions
that we go and take it and then we had
after the assessments we had a question
about the supplemented image again an
education we had a question about so we
had to survey about that and then we had
a weirdo analytical
yeah that's the Fantastic experiment and
I guess I'm imagining that sort of
seemed like the first kind of experiment
you've asked in many contexts because
there's a general discussion education
about Discovery learning you create
constructive learning or direct
instruction I of course we can't answer
it right away so that's how big a great
approach in annotation setting the
parallel in this literature about when
you ask someone a question so that you
can answer this is Cowboy um so that
sounds really exciting
uh so but then I'm going to say what I
think would also excite me is that one
constructs from click screen Behavior
right now a behavioral picture that's
very dated completely data-driven of the
students
um and it's a it's supplemented by the
demographic information you have about
your students about the survey
information about the interview data you
collect and all of those things go
together and they help us create this
comprehensive portrait of each
individual student navigating through
the course and that's the power of this
because we're going to have this for
everyone and we're going to be able to
in a sense start to learn about our
rivers in a different way so what I'm
suggesting is that what excites me as
someone who's going after that goal of
understanding the behavior particularly
from the data terrific perspective
because I look at click screen data and
organizing it is that
we need to also organize the data so
that this could creative data with the
annotations is connected and that will
complement the data we're amassing right
now that describes whether Behavior and
the other behavior of collecting so I
would just be really excited to put
those things together yeah
that's what we know but we're doing that
we're going to be honestly we will be
doing that
one thing that I want to add is that not
just looking at the individual or the
picture of the individual learner but
because of the scale of these courses is
being able to see sort of heat maps of
what what's happening so if I can see if
I've asked you to tag based on these
Concepts this poem for example and you
know everybody is is is doing right it's
highlighting the the right sections of
that text and creating the right tags
and that's great this is what that's the
outcome that I would like but all of a
sudden in one area I see you know
thousands of annotations that are
happening this other area of the text
that has no relation to really what I'm
asking about so obviously there's a
there's an indication that something
went awry some instruction went awry or
or My description of what they should be
doing or the concept that I was
explaining they didn't grasp it so being
able to see also those edges and seeing
where students are actually falling
behind so not just looking at you know
the individual data but the math class
and see how the groups are going and
then drilling a little bit deeper let's
say oh the people the the the English
native speaking students
got this information perfectly the
people in Africa did not get it and is
there a language issue is is what we're
transmitting because the other thing
that we're that we're not realizing is
in the in this edx world is in this mooc
world is that we assume that everybody
has the same learning processes and
culturally right so they're very
different and we're sort of imposing a
way of learning from a more Western
perspective but not looking at what
other people are needing to to learn
saying you have direct generational
questions about your data and scripted
questions about your students you're
saying well you know to my English
language students do differently from my
non-native speakers or do my
geographically you know what America
seems to do with another country but
when you get to the advanced analytics
then you can actually ask predictive
questions or you can find
patterns and anomalies in the data that
you didn't have questions for I think
that would be the exciting potential
here you know to be able to say I didn't
know what the students was going to
emerge with a certain pattern of
behaviors and we can get to those
questions in the data now with the data
of our scale and that's going to go
beyond even you posing questions that's
going to be discovery of knowledge again
yes absolutely
so you mentioned uh that a student could
reply to an annotation so can you
effectively use annotations as many
discussions so that is that is the
ultimate goal is to actually create so
because of these forums are so sure
there's forms have that purpose if
you're talking about you know the entire
course but if you're really discussing
about a video is that contextual
information is having it part of that
and yes being able to have this mini
form it really is that's all it is it's
a discussion forum right now we have it
limited to one reply and we're going to
be working on multiple levels of reply
so people can engage in conversations
around one topic but yes that's the all
the ultimate goal is to do away with the
forums and aggregate all the information
even the information about The Forum
could be aggregated in one area so you
have access to all that one of our
upcoming courses where they wanted to
have students have directed discussions
based on a location
on the planet and so we've built a tool
that you know does a Google map and
allows them to click and and and do that
I looked at this
can just have a map of the world and
they can annotate it and that would be
the start of their discussion for a
location and it would work in exactly
the same way we're actually working
towards that location-based annotations
they're the door to to augmented reality
on a low scale I mean if you think about
it you have map annotations but if I'm
on a location in an archaeological site
I could have information about what is
going on here annotate it and somebody
in a classroom looks at a map at that
archaeological location and actually see
what the conversation is happening right
on that point so yes I mean all of that
and all of this can be and I could say
all right and I'm annotating here and
I'm putting this video that's annotated
so it's all a cross-referencing across
all different media types that we can
bring into the picture yes absolutely
this is something that's that we would
we're trying to continue on with
yeah I think University of Queensland
I'm going to say something at five
because I'm an organizer okay just um I
think at the University of Queensland
there's a few people working on on the
same annotation tools that we are
um
he I think so I'm trying to remember all
the names but uh
right now I'm in a mental block but yes
we have we we actually collaborate with
them because they're on the same
um Consortium to to normalize the
annotations
yes
material so students could annotate
their annotations so yes it's kind of
that cyclical
uh annotation pattern that we would like
to incorporate in the my notes that
aggregated page where all the the
students notes are aggregated
the vision would be to have students
annotate their notes so somebody could
come in and say oh these are your notes
I don't agree with what you're saying so
basically not just replying to that
annotation but actually annotating an
annotation and I do want to point
anything that's
annotate your notes to be your notes you
can check that box and then they won't
show up in the public tab
right now we're just and just we're
having a we're having a little bit of an
issue with the platform right now with
the privacy and public notes but that
we're hoping that will be fixed
sometimes in theory you should be able
to operate no that that is that is the
idea yes so we should thank our speakers
thank you so
um I'm proudly organizing committee and
my job is to tell you to go take the bus
to the dinner okay it's leaving at five
o'clock if you walk out of this door you
go to your left you'll follow it around
and there's an out there's a foyer that
leads to the outside the buses are out
on Vassar Street so you have to go
outside the door and outside the doors
we're going to load up those buses and
as soon as the bus is full it's going to
go off to the JFK Center beautiful
facility beautiful meal great time
please come and join us but you got to
catch the bus and the bus is leaving
all right